Reading about this product, GC-M-A-F, because my friend is taking it at hope for cancer and wondering why we don't all take these types of things extremely regardless of an issue.
Could these be useful as a preventative? Is this something that can be purchased by other friends struggling with cancer at the U.S.?
So GC-M-A-F is a product that stimulates macrophage production and stimulates macrophage attack to cancer cells.
It was a product that was originally made in England years ago, decades ago, and studies were done on it that it was very beneficial and it was injectable.
So it's stimulated macrophage attack on cancer cells, very promising therapy.
But it wasn't something that was patentable because it was made from vitamin D and it was omega-9 fatty acids.
So it was a synthesis of vitamin D and omega-9 fatty acids.
Well, that factory that was making that in the practitioner that was doing the studies, the company that was doing it got shut down by the British Medical Association, which isn't much different as far as their authored authoritarian Nazi-like function as the AMA and the FDA here in the United States.
So they got shut down and disbanded and information was taken and not a good seed.
Then a number of years later there's a company in New Zealand or something like that that started up making it again.
It's not something that we use in our office because we don't do injectables, we don't do anything that would be done on our scope.
But the practitioners that I spoke to that used it were not happy.
So they were using the original GCMAF and then they started using the new GCMAF that began maybe 10 years ago.
And that's what to my knowledge is still available today.
The practitioners that were using the old and switched to the news and it was just different.
It wasn't made the same way they weren't getting the same results.
Now I do realize that there's clinics in Mexico that still use that.
I think there may be even clinics in the US that still use that.
Understand that is just one therapy, one of many, many therapies that you could do to help with a person with cancer alternative therapies I'm talking about.
That's just one.
There's many more that I write about it in my book.
There's many more that I comment on and have videos on on our website.
So do go on our website and look at our blog post.
I think we have a well over a thousand blog posts of different things with cancer.
However, can't so the question is can a person use this preventatively?
I don't know where you would get that for preventative use.
Personally, I wouldn't use it for preventative use.
I would use other things that would more naturally stimulate my immune system.
I would do things to help with detoxification pathways from a preventative basis.
I would do things that would help prevent the causes of cancer.
That would help another good really good thing to do is to do a full genetic workup.
I don't have cancer so I don't want to get cancer.
Should you do it full genetic workup?
Yes, that would be really good.
You see very commonly with cancer patients is deficiencies or issues from a genetic standpoint with their detoxification pathways.
So if you can't detoxify chemicals like fluoride from a question a minute ago, things like that that can settle in your body and get inside a cell.
Remember cancer is cells that are damaged.
The DNA is damaged and they're in rapid replication and the replicated cells that are in rapid replication.
What causes that? Well, it's not genetics that caused that, but something got inside that cell and damaged the nucleus, the DNA and the nucleus.
So what is that something? Well, it could be a virus, it could be a bacteria.
Most commonly, it's a toxin.
So we're exposed to these chemicals, most of these toxins.
They get inside the cell, they can sit there can early until we die, but they can also damage the mitochondria.
They can damage the nucleus, they can damage other organelles in the cell, causing ill health and certainly causing cancer.
So from a preventative standpoint for cancer, I would really look at detoxification pathways and trying to keep my toxic exposure to a minimum as best that possibly can.
Then to think about doing like a GCMAF.